Another way of understanding
what is knowledge based AI,
is to contrast it with the other
schools of thought in AI.
We can think in terms of a spectrum.
On one end of the spectrum, is acting.
The other end of
the spectrum is thinking.
As an example, when you're driving
a car, you're acting on the world.
But when you are planning what route to
take, you're thinking about the world.
There is a second dimension for
distinguishing between different
schools of thought of AI.
At one end of the spectrum we can
think of AI agents that are optimal.
At the other end of the spectrum,
we can think of air agents that act and
think like humans.
Humans are multifunctional,
they have very robust intelligence.
That intelligence need not be optimal
relative to any one task, but
it's very general purpose, it works for
a very large number of tasks.
Were as we can pick up here, agents on
the other side which are optimal for
a given task.
Given these 2 axis we get 4 quadrants.
Starting from the top left and going
counter clockwise, here are Agents that
think optimally, Agents that act
optimally, Agents that act like humans.
And agents that think like humans.
In this particular course
in knowledged based AI,
we're interested in agents
that think like humans.
Let us take a few examples
to make sure that we
understand this four quadrants world.
Here are some well known
computational techniques.
Consider many machine
learning algorithms.
These algorithms analyse
large amounts of data, and
determine patterns of
the regularity of that data.
Well I might think of them as
being in the top left quadrant.
This is really doing thinking,
and they often are optimal, but
they're not necessarily human like.
Airplane autopilots.
They would go under acting optimally.
They're suddenly acting in the world,
and you want them to act optimally.
Improvisational robots that can perhaps
dance to the music that you play,
they're acting, and they are behaving
like humans, dancing to some music.
Semantic web, a new generation
of web technologies in which
the web understands the various pages,
and information on it.
I might put that under
thinking like humans.
They are thinking.
Not acting in the world.
And is much more like humans,
than, let's say,
some of the other
computational techniques here.
>> If you're interested in reading
some more about these projects,
you can check out the course materials.
Where we've provided some recent papers
on these different computational
techniques.
There's a lot of cutting edge research
going on here at Georgia Tech and
elsewhere, on these
different technologies.
And if,
if you really are interested in this,
this is something where we're
always looking for contributors.